oh my name is Mulder
I was born here in New York concept
number 11 1965 well I moved to
Connecticut when I was two I think
actually not two or three and how
Connecticut shaped me it's it's it's an
interesting question I grew up in in
darien connecticut which is a very
affluent suburban bedroom community and
i grew up dirt poor you want my mother
and i were on welfare until i was 18
which was very strange because every
single person i knew in darienne came
from you know they had very affluent
families and came from a lot of money so
it was strange up until I was 18 I was
basically the only poor person I'd ever
met i think it's given me a lifelong
feeling of inadequacy almost a sort of
Jay Gatsby need to kind of prove myself
at times and I mean on a positive side
luckily the public schools were really
good and all my teachers when I was
growing up we're very idealistic
children of the 60s and 70s who sought
public education as a way of really sort
of like establishing this almost like
progressive utopian world so I had great
teachers and great public schools I have
a single defining characteristic I'm
bald that somehow I've have a reputation
for being very serious and I'm not
saying that I'm funny but I think that I
have more of a sense of humor than a lot
of people would give me credit for like
I think people think of me being very
strident and very didactic and earnest
and hopefully none of those things are
the case
you